Speaker 1: So yesterday, as many of you listened
to and
Speaker 2: watched and emailed
Speaker 1: me about, I interviewed Donald
Trump's former attorney, Michael Cohen.
Speaker 2: Now Michael Cohen disagrees with
me.
Or at least, you know, I could
Speaker 1: be swayed, but I've been saying
I don't believe Donald Trump is ultimately
going to be charged with any crime.
Speaker 2: Michael Cohen believes that he
will.
Speaker 1: But Michael's commentary was really
restricted to the financial
Speaker 2: stuff that Michael
Speaker 1: Cohen would know about, meaning
sometimes overstating and sometimes understating
the value of different assets for the purposes
of either obtaining loans or minimizing taxes
or whatever the case may be.
Speaker 2: There is now another layer as to
Speaker 1: the possible criminal charges
Speaker 2: that maybe
Speaker 1: would be coming Donald Trump's
way.
Now, I still am very skeptical that this is
going to become a real thing.
But at this point, there is a member of Congress
that is alluding to it.
And so.
So I do think that it's real enough that we
should be talking about it.
What am I talking about here?
Well, yesterday we played.
We rather we
Speaker 2: reviewed text
Speaker 1: messages that Republican Congresswoman
Liz Cheney read during a hearing which came
from various Fox News hosts and Donald Trump
Speaker 2: Jr. to Donald
Speaker 1: Trump's former chief of staff,
Mark Meadows.
Now we're going to now look at some video
of her talking about
Speaker 2: this, and it's about
Speaker 1: a three minute video.
I'm going to play it also that you get the
full context.
Pay special attention near the end where Cheney
actually says, did Donald Trump, through action
or inaction, corruptly seek to
Speaker 2: obstruct or impede
Speaker 1: Congress's proceedings?
I'll tell you in a moment why that is so relevant.
Let's take a look at the video.
Speaker 3: These text messages leave no doubt
the White House knew exactly what was happening
here at the Capitol.
Members of Congress, the press and others
wrote to Mark Meadows as the attack was underway.
One text Mr Meadows received said quote, We
are under siege here at the Capitol.
Another quote they have breached the Capitol.
In a third mark, protesters are literally
storming the Capitol, breaking windows on
doors, rushing in.
Is Trump going to say something?
A fourth there's an armed standoff at the
House chamber door and another from someone
inside the Capitol.
We are all helpless.
Dozens of texts, including from Trump administration
officials, urged immediate action by the president.
Quote post has to come out firmly and tell
the protesters to dissipate.
Someone is going to get killed.
In another Mark, he needs to stop this now.
A third in all caps, tell them to go home.
A fourth and I quote, Proteus needs to calm
this shit down.
Indeed, according to the records, multiple
Fox News hosts knew the president needed to
act immediately.
They texted Mr. Meadows, and he has turned
over those texts.
Quote, Mark, the president needs to tell people
in the Capitol to go home, this is hurting
all of us.
He is destroying his legacy.
Laura Ingram wrote.
Please get him on TV.
Destroying everything you have accomplished.
Brian Kilmeade texted quote, Can he make a
statement?
Ask people to leave the capital?
Sean Hannity urged as the violence continued.
One of the president's sons texted Mr. Meadows
quote, He's got to condemn this shit ASAP.
The Capitol Police tweet is not enough.
Donald Trump Jr. texted.
Meadows responded quote, I'm pushing it hard.
I agree.
Still, President Trump did not immediately
act.
Donald Trump Jr. texted again and again, urging
action by the president.
Quote, We need an Oval Office address.
He has to lead now.
It has gone too far and gotten out of hand.
End quote.
But hours passed without necessary action
by the president.
These non privileged texts are further evidence
of President Trump's supreme dereliction of
duty during those one hundred and eighty seven
minutes.
And Mr. Meadows testimony will bear on another
key question before this committee did Donald
Trump, through action or inaction, corruptly
seek to obstruct or impede Congress's official
proceedings to count electoral votes?
Mark Meadows testimony is necessary to inform
our legislative judgments.
Speaker 1: OK, so that's a lot of different
things that she said.
But at the end, she says, did Donald Trump
corruptly seek to obstruct or impede Congress's
proceedings?
Speaker 2: This is being considered
Speaker 1: the most direct signal thus far
that there is the possibility that Donald
Trump might be charged
Speaker 2: with pretty
Speaker 1: serious federal crimes.
What Cheney read there
Speaker 2: relates to 18
Speaker 1: U.S. Code subsection 15 five obstruction
of proceedings before departments, agencies
Speaker 2: and committees.
The issue here, of course, being Donald
Speaker 1: Trump's attempts to obstruct investigation
into himself and also attempt to obstruct
the proceedings, which would correctly assess
Joe Biden the winner of the 2020 election.
And it reads, Whoever with intent to avoid,
evade, prevent or obstruct compliance with
any civil investigative demand duly and properly
made, willfully withholds, misrepresents,
removes from any place, conceals, covers up,
et cetera, et cetera.
Shall be fined under this title imprisoned
not more than five
Speaker 2: years, or if it involves
Speaker 1: international or domestic terrorism
up to eight years.
So the idea here is that Liz Cheney is hinting
at possible criminal charges for Donald Trump
over the entire situation.
Now that has exploded for Donald Trump's former
chief of staff,
Speaker 2: Mark Meadows, involving text
Speaker 1: messages involving a PowerPoint,
which very directly said, Here's how we would
do the coup, and here are the different elements
that we would look at doing.
There are a number of different legal analysts
are talking about this, Harvard Law School
Professor Emeritus Laurence Tribe
Speaker 2: pointed out that refers
Speaker 1: specifically to U.S. Code subsection
15 05 18 U.S. Code subsection 15 05.
Speaker 2: And CNN's Elie Honig
Speaker 1: made a similar comment when he
was interviewed by John Berman.
And so this is now going to be a question
of whether or not Donald Trump could get away
with claiming presidential immunity.
Speaker 2: That would be the next layer here.
Imagine that this happens, OK?
And again,
Speaker 1: this is why I see it as unlikely.
But I'm a little bit closer to thinking it's
conceivable that there could be charges, although
the guy is not going to spend the day in prison
if indeed they tried to charge Trump for his
role in any of these various obstructive acts
because there's actually no shortage of them.
He would likely first claim that he had presidential
immunity for anything that he did.
Now the problem with that is how do you justify
Trump's obstructive actions with regard to
investigations into him or directions of others
to obstruct?
How do you justify
Speaker 2: that as a
Speaker 1: presidential duty?
Because at the end of the day?
Immunity.
Is limited based on the legal experts I've
spoken to in the scholarship that I've read.
The immunity is limited to his official duties
or things carried out clearly in his role
as president.
So fortunately or unfortunately, I know many
of you don't like this, but when a president
makes a decision for a country to go to war
and people die as a
Speaker 2: result of that could be American
Speaker 1: troops could be
Speaker 2: foreign troops could be civilians.
Speaker 1: It is very difficult to hold them
accountable as if these were individual criminal
acts because they do have pretty broad presidential
immunity.
Could it be challenged?
Maybe.
But the point here is we are now arguably
outside of that.
The argument that would be made against Trump's
claim of presidential immunity and there's
a bunch of different people who have tweeted
about this and written good commentaries.
How do you justify that Donald Trump's obstructive
acts related to his own wrongdoing?
Would be covered by presidential
Speaker 2: immunity, and there are some people
who say, yeah, if the
Speaker 1: president does it, it's not a crime
of harkening back to Richard Nixon, but there
is a debate about that.
And fundamentally, if there were charges,
Donald Trump would likely try to assert that
he had presidential and has presidential immunity
on the basis of what he did.
Speaker 2: And then it would become well,
are the obstructive
Speaker 1: acts actually
Speaker 2: covered
Speaker 1: by immunity?
And there is an argument to be made that they
are not.
It would be a fight.
It would be a very, very big legal fight could
be ages.
Speaker 2: But the first signal that maybe
there are
Speaker 1: people in Congress, a Republican,
no less
Speaker 2: thinking of crimes
Speaker 1: related to Donald Trump's actions.
Of course, the crimes would be up to the Justice
Department to bring.
It still doesn't seem that Merrick Garland
seems super interested in that.
That'll be a story
for
a different day.